so this is breaking now from
new york city the governor of the state
of new york has reinstated
indoor dining ban in new york city the
positivity rate
is about 5.35 in the city
outdoor dining takeout will continue but
as of
monday this coming monday indoor dining
is now shuttered in new york city
i i want to ask everybody on the panel
today about this a couple of you
actually live in new york city
uh the mayor of new york city de blasio
said that he saw this coming he would
support a hundred percent
whatever the governor would decide
kennedy
uh there are stunning numbers from not
only
businesses that are now going to close
forever but also
commercial real estate it is just
decimated in the city the mayor has no
idea
what to do about it there are counties
outside of new york city that have much
higher positivity rates and
hospitalization rates
and they continue to have indoor dining
and all sorts of other services that are
available restaurants have it figured
out if there is
one sector that has been the most
flexible it is
restaurants and i'm talking partitions
hand sanitizer
distancing digital menus they have it
covered
and you know if you trust yourself and
you trust where you're going you should
be able
to have that interaction safely
brian you know governor cuomo the book
about how he handled i'll just say that
governor cuomo of the book
about how he handled the pandemic uh you
know a
look at by award committees that he did
such a great job
talk to one person our own janice dean
or others whom i've interviewed about
his decision on nursing homes doesn't
the science
need to come forth along with this
announcement i mean front and center and
maybe it will
i mean we're very early on the news is
just breaking but you
you live there uh yeah harris says so
we're in the
long island list around the country the
numbers are better on long island it's
more suburban
than obviously manhattan uh what they
found out when they was when they
reinstated the indoor dining ban
in places like midtown where we are they
found out that
it didn't matter there's nobody around
there's nobody working
in the towns and the sections in the
villages in these little in chelsea and
and different places around the city
upper east side west side where it feels
like a neighborhood
opening makes sense and to kennedy's
point they invested these rocha into
these restaurant tours in separating the
tables
in plexiglass in their kitchens
in order to keep everybody safe and when
they started to make some money
now the numbers went up a little bit
just because they're going up around the
country
to me you don't deserve credit when you
just ban everything and send money home
you deserve credit if you can keep the
small business the economy going
at the same time do your best to keep
people safe all he is good at
is shutting things down and saying no
and taking no responsibility for looting
and shooting
but what he is what he loves to do is
show no empathy
as he tells the small business men and
women who just invested in
food and drinks that all that stuff is
going to go bad and go to a soup kitchen
because now you're out of business and
i'm going to add one more thing to this
to the big picture here
is these people are going out tonight
you ban them from indoor dining i guess
it starts on monday
they're going out tonight and they're
going out monday night but they're going
to go in their apartments
on their rooftops they're going to just
have parties away from you
and those local businesses aren't going
to make money you're not stopping it
you're just moving it yeah good point
tommy oh well i honestly think that uh
governor newsom in california and
governor cuomo in new york i think that
they have a constant daily battle
of who can be more atrocious but again
as brian said these business owners have
the rug pulled out from under them
at every turn they're just being able to
kind of make a little bit of money
nothing like what they should be making
especially around the holiday season but
making a little bit of money and then
the rug pulled out from underneath of
them again and not just the business
owners but the employees these are
people
that are now going to have to rely on
the government for any sort of income
whatsoever which i'm sure is what the
democrats really love to hear
but for most of us who want to make a
living and live our lives that is
absolutely devastating and again as
brian said it seems to be the goal
around many of these especially
liberal states is ban first and then
give the science later
where is the evidence that indoor dining
is what's spreading coronavirus where is
the evidence that this is
the problem that these this action
that's being taken moving people
outside that this is going to solve the
problem lessen the cases
because i know in california they
weren't really able to provide that
information and it's all based on
hearsay anyway
but meanwhile what we do know to be true
and to be a fact
is that small businesses especially in
the restaurant industry are going to be
damaged
irreparably if not shut down entirely
it's enough of this it's time for
americans to say
we are done with this we are going to
live our lives enough with the new
normal
we are going to be safe we are going to
be responsible but we are done living
and worrying about the shadow
that we're going to see in the corner
it's time to get back to normal
emily do you think that the decisions
that some of these lawmakers are making
and the reaction
from our panel so far in just these last
few minutes spelling it out what it's
really like to live on the ground
and of course you know our hearts are
breaking
every day because we can't seem to stop
the spread
but on the west coast they close down
outdoor dining and there's certainly no
scientific
scientific basis for that do you think
that there are long-term
repercussions legally
absolutely there are long-term
repercussions in a whole multitude of
arenas so firstly
first we've talked about before the
whole host of lawsuits we saw in the
beginning of the shutdowns right
and a lot of focus was on the
constitutional right infringements right
the right to worship etc
and we know that that's a strict
scrutiny standard by the courts
meaning it's a really high to cross if
you choose to trample on someone's
constitutional rights you have to have
an excellent reason for doing so and it
has to be neatly tied
to that specific action that you are
prohibiting or allowing
now with this kind of decision it's just
rational basis
it's a lower standard for these
government officials to make it makes it
harder
for these restaurants it makes it harder
for these small businesses that being
said we saw a victory in california
right with the california restaurant
association where they said
to tommy's point and brian's point there
isn't science differentiating between
indoor and outdoor dining transmission
rates and therefore the courts ruled in
their favor
and to to kennedy's point i think the
ripple effect we will see
in the mortgage industry and and a
million more things i don't have time to
go into now
that those effects will be astronomical
for years to come